[Music]
new details this hour on the drought on
the Colorado River with news breaking
that this week that Nevada made a deal
with California and Arizona to cut water
usage over the next couple of years
Nevada congresswoman Susie Lee and our
neighbor to the west joining forces
today to try and break down the details
of that deal eight news now investigator
Kyle Payne is at Lake Mead with those
details
those three states you mentioned
California Arizona and Nevada say they
have a plan to reduce the precious water
you see behind me but we had very few
details before today and we have very
few details as we speak this turned out
not to be a press briefing on the nuts
and bolts of the agreement Nevada
congresswoman Susie Lee and her
California counterpart Congressman David
valadeo we're joining forces as much for
what they said with an opportunity for
the politicians to learn about each
other's districts as it was the water
when we pressed officials for details
today they said they simply didn't have
any and also weren't prepared to discuss
them what this agreement does is buys us
three and a half years we are still in
the middle of a drought even though we
had an incredible snowpack year as you
can see Lake Mead is still at 30 percent
of its capacity and so our hope is that
during this interim we can come to an
agreement on using water more
efficiently the congresswoman said over
two-thirds of the water the states have
agreed to cut will come from incentives
to Farmers and other other big water
users who haven't necessarily
volunteered to conserve any more water
than they already are the exact number
of the three states have agreed to cut
is three million acre feet which is
about 20 percent of the water used from
the river but even that number isn't set
in stone reporting at Lake Mead Kyle
Payne 8 News Now
by the way you can watch our special
report called California Water Hogs this
coming Monday night at 6 30. Kyle Payne
went to California to investigate
whether it is doing enough to conserve
water or if they are being water hogs
again that special air is Monday at 6 30
right here on Channel 8.